let's talk about another team from the
eastern division of the other conference
that
is almost as bad right now as the
cowboys but not quite
let's hear matthew slater
special teams captain a long time
fixture of the patriots franchise
monday night patriot show on nbc sport
boston
talking about uh issues with the
patriots as of right now
you know i think that there were times
uh
last night where we let the attitude and
effort part slip away from us
um you know that's never acceptable so i
think
we're gonna have to to make sure we are
on that
each and every play never taking
anything for granted i mean
we're so blessed to be able to play this
game and we owe it to the game
to go out and and pay it as pay the
respect that it's due
and approach this thing the right way
attitude and effort was attitude and
effort ever a problem for the patriots
during the last 20 years was attitude
and effort ever an issue during the time
that you were locked in the closet up
there working for the team
no never never i mean you're right you
don't ever hear those type of words
you know from the new england patriots
again that's why i'll go into
out of all the teams with covid and
everything like that i'll make more
excuses for new england
because their greatest asset is their
damn head coach who's the
genius of all geniuses and the fact that
he hasn't been able to keep this team
you know under his thumb or whatever
else all the time
to where he can always nitpick and
adjust and do everything like that
it's really hurt them and it hurt them
on sunday of course where they were
overwhelmed
by a more intense physical san francisco
more talented
san francisco 49ers football team at
what point does he just accept the fact
that
this isn't the year that it's not going
to work he's not going to be able to
coach the way he wants to he can't have
the meetings the way that he does
all of the things that worked for him in
the past he's just
not able to do them this year you know
we didn't see a whole lot of fire from
him
in the aftermath of the loss to the
49ers no there was no on to cincinnati
moment there was no defiance there was
none of that stuff that would
that would be indicative of that
pushback
on those rare occasions in the past when
we see the patriots on the ropes i just
wonder if he's just getting worn out by
all of this stuff
well you know he's got he's got a lot of
new parts got a young you know a new
quarterback thing like that where i
think you know first off he might not
want to be that way with this football
team realizing he might not have the
right leadership there or whatever that
would react the right way
maybe staying a little bit more positive
with this football team right now
just to build some confidence within
them you know
that that would be the but they'll never
quit mike they'll never he he will never
the coaching staff up there
at no point you know they'll continue
even with yeah
these curveballs they're being thrown by
like you're talking about the zoom
meetings and all that
the one thing you can count on is they
will continue to dissect their approach
and to figure out what is the most
efficient way
to get it done right now hey they're
back in the building
we've talked about i think the bills are
the right team for them to kind of get
back on track they match up well i'm not
saying they're going to win
but yeah last week was the first time in
a really long time
where you saw the will of the new
england patriots ripped out of their
chest
right i mean the game went like this it
was a five and out
it was a good drive for a field goal it
was an interception on the first play
the next drive and then the three and
out and the game was 23 to three
i mean new england didn't have much of a
chance and and shanahan and that san
francisco running game
just abused them to the point where i
think they realized like wait
i don't care what day it is i don't
think we can match up with this football
team and i think they realized that in
about the second quarter where they were
like i don't think we have a chance
today
and you just don't see that from new
england very often or ever really
at bills at jets and then the ravens on
sunday night football
the patriots could get to four and four
and
you know it was a game against the
ravens last year that kind of
burst the bubble on a patriots team that
looked
as good as any patriots team ever has
maybe it's a ravens game this year that
is the moment where we all say holy crap
they figured it out and
look no further than the 49ers for proof
that it is possible to figure things out
yeah blown off the field by the dolphins
think about that 43-17 loss to miami and
then turn around two weeks later
and beat the patriots 33-6 and dominate
yeah worst home loss since 1998 before
bill belichick was even with the team
so that there's hope for patriots fans
cowboys fans know
patriots fans yes that's the difference
well patriots still hope into to
that's right the patriots have some
still elite things about their team
where you go okay i mean they still have
an elite head coach we know that
they're secondary and that is still
elite and then
if their o-line can just be together
here and healthy
like they have it's it's borderline
elite as well with their run game
so if they can kind of just get those
two things going it gives them a
fighting chance
that that's at least there is a little
light at the end of the tunnel for new
england yeah i'm not expecting super
bowl or anything like that but
i'm still not giving up on them like
we've talked about as far as being a
playoff football team not quite yet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports